retour en france avec ce rassemblement
contre la loi séparatisme à paris sur
appel de plusieurs associations et à la
veille de la journée mondiale contre
l'islamophobie la loire contre le
séparatisme texte adopté par les députés
prochainement soumis aux sénateurs
plusieurs dispositifs de la loi pose
problème aux organisateurs de la
mobilisation une craignent entre autres
un ciblage des musulmans le point sur
cette mobilisation avec un autre
reporter mais qu'elle disait ces
manifestants étaient rassemblés ici sur
la place de la république pour lutter
contre l'islamophobie et contre les lois
qu'ils jugent des islamophobes en
premier lieu desquels la loi sur les
séparatismes ils craignent avec cette
loi de se retrouver stigmatisés en tant
que musulman ce qui selon eux est une
véritable entorse à la liberté
religieuse notre liberté celui qui est
bafouée par cette loi la liberté
d'association
ils craignent des dissolutions massive
d'organisation mais je vous propose
d'écouter plusieurs manifestants que
j'ai pu interviewer au début de cette
manifestation il y à une loi qui est
débattue et maintenant au sénat
ce qui est loi raciste qui est loi
islamophobe qui est une déclaration de
guerre contre la communauté musulmane et
contre les musulmans en france avec la
volonté de vouloir les rabaisser les
dixièmes anisé et les chasser de las de
la vie sociale et politique publique
c'est derrière une volonté de cantonner
les musulmans et l'islam à la secteur
privé et que toutes expressions
publiques sociales culturelles
cultuelles et politique de l'islam est
une volonté de la condamnée et de la
chasse et de l'espace là cette loi c'est
une loi c'est tout qui veulent faire une
loi séparatiste a comme ça c'est très
mauvais pour la france et c'est très
mauvais pour le peuple
et parce que petit à petit je pense je
pense qu'il y aura aussi les
syndicalistes et après tout associations
quelles qu'elles soient a sera réprimée
de la même manière que les gens fous de
tout ce qui se met pas d'être bien dans
la tête que c'est l'appareil
cet appel à manifester il intervient à
la veille d'une journée nationale de
protestation au but et à la veille d'une
commémoration celle de l'attentât de
christchurch en nouvelle zélande à voir
où sa cote est un musulman avait été
assassiné par le bel horizon reste
intacte
c'était le 14 mars 2019 c'est aussi
l'occasion pour eux de réclamer le
retrait doit nous loi votée en 2004 sur
l'interdiction du hidjab du voile à
l'école et dans les établissements
scolaires musulmans